this is an ultra black and in case you
missed the memo ultra blacks are the new
black
these light capturing coatings have been
used to cover luxury cars and even make
art projects like this black hole which
was so black a viewer actually fell in
their depth perception rendered useless
by the optical illusion that black hole
is an artwork by the artist Anish Kapoor
who controversially secured exclusive
rights to use what was then the blackest
coating called vantablack in his work
that upset a lot of other artists who
also wanted to use these blackest blacks
this is so rude you've got to make a
black who's better than his black that's
Stuart's simple and he created this
paint which is one of the blackest
paints you can buy
but here's the thing there are blacker
blacks and scientists are measuring just
how much light they can capture our
blacks are the blackest that we know of
that's John layman a scientist at the
National Institute for Standards and
Technology he has helped develop one of
the blackest ultra blacks yet the
not-so-secret sauce carbon nanotubes
which can only really be seen under
powerful magnification carbon nanotubes
are structure made of a layer of
graphene some millionth of the diameter
of a human hair
those nanotubes blacks might have
military applications be useful for
photography and to make ever more
accurate sensors so why do we care I
spoke to both simple and layman to find
out what's behind this race to make the
most light trapping substances yet but
first let's watch some paint dry for you
this journey really began with Anish
Kapoor and sort of locking up of the
blackest black if that hadn't happened
would there be this race to create the
blackest black in the art world that
would have been because I don't in the
art world wouldn't even know that there
was a material
sniff it have stayed in astronomy or
defense or military or something we
wouldn't have known it existed but
because an itch was using it artists
sort of tuned into it and then we
realized that we wanted to have a go and
use something like that
- we're artists we're interested in what
you can see with your eye so really it
doesn't matter what it's doing in the
infrared spectrum and UV spectrum in a
science lab what we want is a really
flattened boy looking like we can make
work with so if you put it next to
vantablack
yeah it kind of looks similar to the
naked eye but if you start measuring it
smells different why do you think people
are so excited about the idea of
creating the blackest black paint I
think artists have always been very
interested in black because it's
actually not a color and we're talking
about the absence of light and since the
beginning of time so when you're going
about trying to make a paint that is not
a color but the absence of color where
do you begin a lot of the other super
black things that you say scientific
processes and they're incredible but
they're made in labs and they drone
nanotubes and they've made in vacuum
tones it's complicated we approached it
like paint makers so black 3 isn't the
same things you know these Fanta blacks
or singularity black you although it
does have no no particles in it it is
very much obtained so we have to create
a new pigment from scratch called black
magic which is born Matt can you tell me
about some of the ways you've seen black
3.0 being used in the wild I've seen it
used in so many exciting ways you know
we always wanted to make something
usable so that was the whole point
astronomers are using it amateur
astronomers inside their telescopes so
they reflect less light photographers
using it inside camera bodies magicians
are using it sure this paint is cool and
it makes for some pretty neat art
projects but scientists are pushing for
these light absorbing materials for
different reasons this is a microscopic
image of a forest of carbon nanotubes
that's what makes the most light
absorbing ultra blacks work so well
carbon nanotubes are structure made of a
layer of graphene a millionth of the
diameter of a he
so how do these carbon nanotubes capture
particles of light or photons as
scientists call them so basically what
we're doing when we make something very
black is we're creating this topology
where in if photons intersect this
coating they rattle around until they
get absorbed but making light absorbing
carbon nanotubes isn't easy it has to be
done under careful conditions each lab
does it a little differently but the
basics are roughly the same so when
you're developing this extremely black
light absorbing surface you have to
start with these nanotubes how are those
grown or developed so let's say we're
going to make some carbon nanotubes so
we do in fact grow them in a nun
evacuated oven that is it has a vacuum
and we're going to introduce carbon into
that oven and that's going to be the
basis of the nanotubes so we're going to
grow the nanotubes on a substrate which
is in our case of silicon you can think
of that of the cookie sheet and then
we're going to grease the cookie sheet
with iron and then as the substrate
heats up and the carbon is introduced
the nanotubes will start to grow from
the substrate and the longer we bake it
so to speak duck taller the nanotubes
will grow after that we take it out of
the oven and we have a wafer with
nanotubes on it so the whole point of
this is more than just a vanity project
we're not just trying to make the
blackest black because it makes for cool
art or because it's a great thing to
brag about but because there are real
practical applications of this stuff
what do you think are some of the most
important things we can do with these
blackest blacks we're not just trying to
make the black as black we're trying to
make useful detectors right so the
carbon nanotube coatings on a detector
allow us to do better measurements of
the temperature of the earth there is
room for you know 10 times improvement
over what's been done the temperature
measurements we have of the earth right
now could be improved by a factor of 10
with your instruments there's a
difference between what we can do in the
lab on earth and what we can do in space
so our goals for what we're doing in
space are approaching at 10 times
improvement and because we can put them
on small fast relatively inexpensive
detectors means we can put them into
space
more readily I'm imagining these sort of
satellites painted with the blackest
black coating being launched into space
is that sort of accurate or can you
describe what you've actually sent into
space so for the blackest coatings that
we put on detectors they're typically
part of a larger instrument so the
detector might be you know a few
millimeters by a millimeter and it's
buried inside this instrument that has a
prism and some optics and so on so it's
taking that light dispersing it picking
a wavelength and looking at it very
closely and do you just have the one
satellite or what kind of scale are we
talking about right now we just have one
satellite we've just launched our first
one and we have another one planned this
obviously isn't the first attempt to
make an ultra black black there are
other materials like vantablack is one
that's been in the headlines a lot black
3.0 paint is another one what makes your
black different than those ones we are
interested scientifically in this
question of you know what's the blackest
black and and and to be frank I mean we
have a publication which shows that our
blacks are the blackest that we know of
and we've rigorously defended the
uncertainties and the measurement method
and you know in a spirit of scientific
progress I would challenge anybody else
to do the same and see if they agree
with us by your own measurements the
material you've developed captures some
small percentage of more light than
anything else out there that's what we
believe when we get to this level of
blackness we're in this realm of well is
it really the blackest black or is it
the best measurement of the blackest
black and so at least in the scientific
world or you know for us where
we have to know very accurately we put
effort into dances so I don't know how
much blacker we can make something and
actually know that we made it blacker
because there's such a small amount of
light being reflected back that it
becomes increasingly hard to measure at
that amount of light yes exactly exactly
thank you so much for joining us it's
great to talk to you thank you
[Music]